alors comme vous les problèmes remarqués
non voyants ou même peut-être pourquoi
pas super voyant pourquoi je me permets
de dire ça la réponse est dans mon
parcours
si vous me permettez je vais prendre
quelques minutes pour vous parler de ma
vie je suis né à chamonix et à l'âge de
17 ans je suis parti aux états unis afin
de rentrer dans une université
américaine
mais pour cela il fallait que je passe
mon bac j'ai étudié là-bas par
correspondance je prenais un gros risque
mais je suivais mes enfants mes
intuitions j'ai réussi les deux jeux
sortis de cette école avec un avec une
master en communication et
spécialisation en tant que metteur en
scène je quittais los angels and boston
pour los angeles est arrivé à los
angeles le fle le milieu du film de
sauver nommément c'était parce que
j'attendais c'est parce que dont je
rêvais du coup on m'a proposé une autre
direction
dans le monde des catalogues de mode et
j'ai commencé au bas de l'échelle
apprenant petit à petit commencé à
fréquenter les directeurs artistiques
je trouvais le milieu fascinant c'était
comme être un metteur en scène de chaque
image un an et demi plus tard je
quittais cette boîte représenté comme
directeur artistique pour une grande
chaîne de magasins américains pour la
presse mode de cette chaîne
j'avais côtoyé les directeurs
artistiques mais j'en étais pas alors
j'ai décidé de faire jouer un rôle le
rôle de l'acteur qui apprend à jouer par
coton côtoyant donc des professionnels
du rôle qui va jouer c'était exactement
ce que je faisais je prenais là encore
une fois un risque mais une fois de plus
je suivais mise en test mais mes
intuitions
je commençais je commence à me dire
pardon que de toute manière quoi qu'il
se passe je fasse une erreur que je
j'apprendrai quelque chose jeu sortirait
gagnant de cette expérience
c'était dur mais je vous rappeler à ce
moment là d'une interview que j'avais vu
l'interview télévisée
c'était un acteur qui parlait justement
de sa carrière on lui demandait comment
il avait réussi aussi bien et il a dit
quelque chose qui m'est restée qui m'a
frappé il a dit en fin de compte dans la
vie il faut toujours s'entourer de gens
qui sont bien meilleurs que nous le gens
qui en savent beaucoup plus et ne pas
hésiter à les côtoyer alors posé
beaucoup de questions je suivi ce
conseil qui était vraiment un très bon
conseil donc je m'entoure est de gens je
possède énormément de questions et petit
petit à petit sur le terrain j'appris le
job de directeur artistique
je restais dans cet ordre dans cette dja
pour environ deux ans puis après ayant
pris de la confiance nous sentons
capables
j'ai commencé mon propre studio de
publicité
les cités presse et à travers les
contacts que j'avais eu à travers mon
job j'ai pu créer une section que j'ai
vendu au grand magazine de mode
américain qui s'appelait looking raid
pour en français c'est super look quoi
et du coup j'avais fait quelque chose
qui est assez nouveau c'était à mélanger
donc la publicité et l'éditorial c'était
comme un look de publicité d'éditorial
mais c'était vraiment de publicité donc
je faisais des sections pour tous ces
magazines chaque mois après une cliente
à moi m'approche je me dit écoute
j'aimerais monter une agence de
publicité dans le monde du parfum un
monde très luxurieux et le projet
m'emballe à elle avait établi elle avec
eux comment construit en fin de compte
un système qui était pris par les patchs
médicaux ou à l'intérieur il y avait
quelques gouttes de parfum et qui
étaient placés dans des publicités dans
les encarts publicitaires sur les
magazines et du coup les gens étaient
capables d'ouvrir ces petits patches de
se mettre du parfum sur la main les
l'idée au début était dure à vendre et
il y avait pas mal de fautes dans la
production
donc je lui ai demandé d'aller voir les
clients qui était un petit peu déçue par
ce procédé est d'essayer de leur de
rattraper les comptes
je leur donnais différentes options de
placement de ces patchs sur leurs
campagnes publicitaires et pour les
rassurer j'aurais promis de les suivre
de super league et l'exécution de ces
campagnes jusqu'à la fin une fois de
plus je m'avançais dans quelque chose
que je connaissais pas parce que j'avais
aucune idée de comment ces patchs était
construit la technique derrière ces
patchs
donc là encore je me suis mise sur le
terrain et a pris par les spécialistes
les techniciens tous les gens qui
savaient tout de ce procédé
après deux ans j'avais réussi à ouvrir
un bureau à new york puis un bureau à
paris
et du coup j'avais tous les grands noms
donc des fragrances du milieu donc pris
soin paris new york ou los angeles une
grosse boîte américaine donc qui était
un peu notre compétition avait perdu
tous leurs atouts leur compte puisqu'on
a vu on avait vraiment pris tous les
comptes des du monde du parfum approcha
donc la directrice et présidente de la
boîte en lui disant voilà on sera
intéressé de racheter votre votre boîte
mais il y avait une condition là dedans
c'est que je vienne avec eux à new york
ce mot là ma vie était jésus mais
merveilleuses
je gagnais beaucoup d'argent on en tant
que bonus sur toutes les ventes que je
faisais je vis un salaire à six chiffres
je revenais de paris j'étais assez
emballé parce que j'avais décidé de
commencer de gros travaux sur ma ville à
los angeles
je me suis aperçu à ce moment là qu'il y
avait comme un petit rideau noir sur le
côté droit de mon oeil je me disais le
compte de la fatigue des décalages
horaires
parce que j'étais tous les mois entre
paris new york et los angeles
je veux qu'on s'était donc un
ophtalmologue à abolir hills qui
maintenant savent vraiment froidement
jeu j'avais un virus qui s'appelait le
cytomégalovirus en cours le cmv de ce
virus allait attaquer mes yeux des
tâches et la rétine détruire le nerf
optique que je deviendrais totalement
aveugle de plus il allait continuer et
attaquer mon cerveau j'avais de grandes
possibilités de mourir
c'était très dur à entendre
c'était ma vie qui s'écroule est devant
moi c'était angoissant
six mois plus tard j'étais aveugle
demande de mon oeil droit
et mon oeil gauche s'est dit oriet
énormément je devais continuer à
travailler parce que la vente de l'agent
s'était basé sur ma collaboration avec
la nouvelle compagnie j'allais même à
new york ou pour travailler dans leurs
bureaux
il faisait des traitements de
chimiothérapie que je cachais pas ce que
j'avais trois heures à 4 heures de
chimiothérapie par jour que je faisais
moi-même
la compagnie se vendent art et moi je me
réveillais le 5 novembre 1995 dans mon
lit à los angeles avec une vue avec une
maison en travaux et aveugle quoi faire
j'avais déjà à meurent à propriété est
maison puisque j'étais maintenant dans
une situation complètement différente et
factures j'avais arrêté de travailler
naturellement les factures arrivent et
il fallait continuer à les payer les
états unis quand vous avez des maladies
rares c'est vraiment pas un pays même
s'ils avaient de très bonnes assurances
pour y être
tout coûte très très cher l'argent que
j'avais commencé à diminuer de plus en
plus je continue à payer des impôts
parce que même si vous êtes face à la
mort
les clés les factures continuent à venir
je devais continuer à me battre et pour
cela j'ai dû prendre une décision
c'était de vendre cette maison je devais
déjà la finir j'ai commencé à découvrir
à travers le toucher à travers les sons
à travers les odeurs à travers les
énergies même découvert des façons de
mesurer mesurer mon espace de ressentir
l'énergie des couleurs
avec tout ça je décidé de finir cette
maison la maison fini je les mises sur
le marché à un prix où tous les agents
immobiliers me disais que ce moment là
la situation économique aux états unis
était dur de ma maison où elle était la
taille ou les terres prouvait est mis
qu'un certain prix je continuais à
écouter mes intuitions et j'ai mis cette
maison a beaucoup plus cher
les premiers gens qui sont venus voir
ces maisons les agents et les clients
étrangement n'utilisez pas le mot tous
ces mots que j'avais l'habitude
d'entendre des mots comme jolie beau
mais parlait de sentir bien dans un
endroit où vous avez pas envie de partir
tout d'un coup j'étais rentré dans un
monde qui était plus un monde visuel qui
était plus un monde esthétique mais je
rentrais dans un monde qui était vu
sensorielle un nom un monde qui était
basée sur des énergies des ressentis et
là j'avais compris je les y ai une
transition avait été faite transition
que je pourrai jamais revenir derrière
tout cela était basé sur mes sens ses
cinq sens et que le monde de visuels
avec disparu je vendais la maison très
bien donc au dessus de ce côté tout ce
qu'on m'avait prédit
et là je me posais une autre question
j'allais prendre une nouvelle chance à
nouveau en termes tournant dans ma vie
que faire j'ai décidé d'acheter deux
autres maisons qui est en très mauvais
état
je refuse la même chose en utilisant
cette nouvelle technique que j'avais
trouvé j'appellerai le design sensoriel
je refuse à la première maison elles se
vendent à au dessus du prix du marché ce
qui est possible aux états unis alors
que ce n'est pas en france
j'ai cinq offres au dessus du prix que
j'ai demandé c'était extraordinaire
mais c'était aussi quelque chose qui me
faisait peur et c'est là où j'ai réalisé
que plutôt que d'avoir peur j'allais
utiliser cette énergie pour faire ma
deuxième maison
je faisais la même chose cette maison
premier jour sur le marché
j'avais cette offre alors que tous les
agents même avait donné un maximum d'un
certain montant
j'avais dépassé de bien ce mac ce
montant j'avais même des gens qui met
crûment écrivait des lettres et me
disais je me sens très bien tellement
bien chez vous que j'aimerais vraiment
s'il vous plaît vendée moi ma maison
c'était extraordinaire
du coup la maison vendue j'ai décidé
d'ouvrir mon propre ou au bureau
d'architecturé de design d'intérieur la
mêlée midi et là je commence à être
assez médiatisé ce qui me permet assez
vite d'avoir des clients
est-ce que je réalisais à ce moment là
était quelque chose qui est très
important
je réalisais que les clients qui
venaient me voir c'était des gens qui
avaient besoin de changement c'était des
gens qui avaient des problématiques de
vie et que non seulement mon rôle était
de créer un nouveau nouvel endroit pour
eux mais aussi de les accompagner dans
leurs problématiques et j'aurais dû le
comprendre avant parce que quand moi
j'ai fini ma maison j'ai quand j'ai fini
ma maison j'avais ce sentiment que cette
maison mais pratiquement guérie ce qui
était d'ailleurs intéressant parce que
quand je suis allé voir mes médecins
le médecin était complètement étonné que
finalement je commençais à gagner la
bataille contre la mort ma santé avait
repris le dessus et le virus s'était
arrêté
du coup une réalisation c'est que notre
environnement peut nous soigner
continuons donc de avec ses révélations
je me rappelais d'une amie à moi qui
m'avait dit quand tout ça comment ça se
passe et je lui ai dit je vous comprends
pas ce qui se passe elle m'avait dit
donc d'user eric peut-être que ce que tu
vis aujourd'hui c'est peut-être pour le
partager avec les autres
c'est peut-être pour montrer sa
résilience et pour montrer aussi que
tout est possible on peut se battre si
on y croit tout ça m'avait frappé et là
ce message revenez et je me suis dit
c'est vrai c'est vrai que rien ne m'a
jamais arrêté dans la vie c'est vrai que
j'ai toujours su suivre mes intuitions
c'est vrai que j'ai toujours cru que
tout était possible
du coup j'ai décidé de partager ce
message j'ai dit oui à tous les
interviews télévisées comme proposait
aux interviews de radio de presse chaque
fois j'avais la même question qui
revenait les gens disaient toujours mais
comment vous faites vous êtes aveugle
comment vous faites du coup je vous les
donne réponse à tout cela en proposant à
une grande chaîne de télévision
américaine de faire une émission de télé
qui pouvait non seulement montrer
comment je travaillais pour montrer que
le visuel n'était pas forcément une un
impératif pour faire du design est
également pour montrer qu'à travers le
design à travers qu'on crée un
environnement donc en harmonie avec tous
nos sens
on pouvait également créé le bien-être
chez les personnes
le sorte de synergie entre les énergies
de l'environnement et leur énergie
du coup aujourd'hui ma vie est vraiment
différente
j'aime partager ce message je fais
beaucoup de conférences
je partage aussi donc ce nouveau design
sensoriel dans les écoles d'architecturé
et de design et on profite pour dire à
mes étudiants raconter un peu mon
histoire
alors dire que tout est possible je fais
aussi du coaching personnel du coaching
d'entreprise est souvent ce qui est
intéressant parce qu'on est quand même
dans un monde où tout est train de
changer
ou on est au moins a besoin de se
renouveler on a besoin de trouver de
nouvelles solutions de nouvelle façon de
voir le monde
alors peut-être que quelqu'un qui a
perdu la vue
justement donné de nouvelles clés parce
que moi même j'étais obligé de changer
ma façon de voir de changer ma façon de
faire les choses
donc quand les gens me disent souvent ah
bah faut faire comme si aujourd'hui je
veux dire il faut faire comme si offert
comme ça est la réponse est généralement
ah non ça c'est pas possible et à ça je
dis pas comment on le rend possible et
c'est ça qui m'intéresse aujourd'hui
comment on rend les choses possibles
parce que ce qui est merveilleux avec le
manque de vue c'est qu'on n'est pas
influencée par ce qu'on voit pas ce
qu'on a là on est déjà dans la solution
on est déjà dans ce qui peut être fait
après donc voilà je vais finir par vous
dire
que rentrer plus souvent dans le noir
fermez les yeux
regardez à l'interview de vous-même
ressentez tous vos sens c'est nrj vous
avez une à l'intérieur de vous ressentez
l'énergie de votre environnement des
gens autour de vous et avec tout cela
vous verrez mieux et peut-être même ce
serait comme moi un super voyant merci